Colette texte de Chiara arsengo et
Aymeric Vincenot illustration de Chiara
arsengo océan jeunesse
comme elle aimait le faire chaque matin
en se réveillant Colette se blottit
tendrement dans les bras de son mari
Ernest je n'avais jamais remarqué à quel
point tu veux devenir poilu en
vieillissant lui réglisse a-t-elle en
riant ni à quel point tes poils
devenaient blancs elle eu d'autres
réponses qu'un ronflement satisfait
une fois levé elle s'assie devant sa
coiffeuse et appliqua son masque de
beauté n'ayant pas chaussé ses lunettes
elle plie sa les yeux et se trouva une
drôle de tête moi non plus vieillir ne
me réussit pas plaisanta-t-elle sans
remarquer le pandac qui face à elle
s'amuser à reproduire ces moindres
gestes
elle se glissa dans la baignoire en
poussant ce qu'elle croyait être son
mari
Ernest tu sais bien qu'il n'y a pas de
place pour nous deux dans cette
baignoire nous sommes désormais trop
gros pour nous baigner ensemble à son
grand étonnement elle une fois encore
pas de réponse et du consentir à
partager son bain
se sentant décidément à l'étroit elle
sortira rapidement et sa fille de
nouveau devant sa glace le panda avait
disparu et elle se trouva bien meilleur
mine elle commença à s'appliquer de la
poudre sur le visage et la caresse du
pinceau lui semblable bien plus douce
que d'habitude elle s'étonna ensuite car
sa brosse semblait bouger mais elle
trouva ce massage inattendu bien
agréable
une fois prête Colette s'attaqua à ses
tâches habituelles d'abord étendre le
linge se dit-elle à voix haute en se
saisissant du bac sans pouvoir son
Chablis confortablement endormi au
sommet du tas de vêtements et après un
pantalon et une jupe Billy se retrouva
tête en bas suspendue au fil
le linge est tendu il était temps de
sortir Balto le chien qu'as-tu donc
aujourd'hui Balto est-ce toi qui tire
plus fort que d'habitude sur la laisse
ou moi qui n'ai plus la force de te
tenir questionnaire Colette peinant à
suivre un impressionnant reptile qui
n'était pas mal tôt sans voir les
regards effrayés des voisins
une fois rentré Colette du CE hisser sur
la pointe des pieds pour suspendre à
bout de bras son manteau je me tasse de
plus en plus il faudra que je demande à
Ernest de refixer le porte-manteau un
peu plus bas pense à Colette Colette
décida ensuite de repeindre le salon
tâche qu'elle repousse et depuis
longtemps déjà
elle s'attarda particulièrement à un
endroit du mur toutes ces tâches noires
se mur méritaient bien un coup de neuf
la peinture terminée il était l'heure
d'aller chercher Julie sa petite fille à
l'école Colette enfila son manteau qui a
eu une fois encore du mal à décrocher
tant il était haut puis pris son étale
et son sac
seul Julie remarqua que la fourrure
autour du cou de sa grand-mère remuée et
la regarder d'un air amusé après son
goûter Julie alla dans sa chambre mais
quelques minutes plus tard elle entendit
sa grand-mère qui parlait elle parle
toute seule maintenant ce demanda à la
petite fille dans le salon elle vit
Colette qui malgré ses lunettes sur le
nez intime et un étrange lézard qu'elle
semble et confondre avec Julie d'aller
faire ses devoirs je n'ai pourtant pas
une tête de lézard rigoler à la fillette
mais que faisait donc cet animal dans le
salon de sa grand-mère
Julie trop contente de ne pas avoir à
faire ses devoirs se garde à bien
d'intervenir Colette Satie à son bureau
cherche en désespérément la plume avec
laquelle elle émet traditionnellement
écrire sa liste de commissions elle
pense à l'avoir trouvé sur le derrière
d'une autruche qui passait par là et qui
lui offrit un morceau de son plumage un
peu contre son gré
Colette à plat Julie pour qu'elle
l'accompagne faire ses courses elle crut
la voix dans l'entrée déjà vêtue de son
manteau rouge et lui pris la main avant
de sortir au marché les commerçants
étaient partagés en l'incrédulité et
l'amusement en voyant cette grand-mère
d'habitude si normal promener un singe
mais personne ne voulut faire de
commentaires de peur de paraître impoli
auprès d'une fidèle cliente
en rentrant elle se rendit à la cuisine
en entendant Colette le kangourou tenta
de se cacher surprise non seulement la
vieille dame ne le voyait pas mais en
plus il n'aurait plus besoin d'aller se
servir car la vieille dame range ses
courses dans sa poche ventrale
Colette puis enfin s’asseoir
confortablement devant la télévision
juste à l'heure pour son feuilleton
quotidien elle pesta contre la
télécommande qui refusait de fonctionner
tout en continuant d'appuyer avec
insistance sur la carapace d'une petite
tortue qui agitait les pattes pour
s’échapper Colette était encore
contrarié d'avoir raté son feuilleton
quand son mari rentra à la maison
Ernest rit en voyant ses propres
lunettes sur le nez de sa femme
tu ne t'es même pas rendu compte que
nous avons échangé nos lunettes ce matin
je suis partie avec les tiennes lui
explicative à ce cela ne m'a pas du tout
gêné lui répondit-elle en revanche la
télécommande ne fonctionne plus j'ai
raté mon feuilleton et je n'ai pas pu
voir les informations tu ne connais donc
pas la dernière les animaux du zoo se
sont échappés la nuit dernière il paraît
qu'ils étaient maltraités en tout cas
ils sont introuvables lui a pris son
mari et bien ils ne sont certainement
pas ici je les aurai vu assurra Colette
en rentrant dans sa chambre elle
s'émerveilla des dizaines d'étoiles
brillant à travers la pièce
le lendemain Colette fut réveillé par
des bruits provenant de la cuisine elle
y trouva les animaux qui préparaient le
petit déjeuner
Ernest vient voir à Platel se demanda si
elle n'avait pas une fois de plus
emprunter les lunettes de son mari
Ernest se frotta longuement les yeux
avant de se rendre à l'évidence les
animaux avaient trouvé refuge chez eux
Colette réussit à convaincre Ernest de
les garder son mari pourtant s'inquiéter
nous ne sommes plus tout jeunes et ces
animaux vont nous donner du travail en
plus
ils avaient tort les animaux au
contraire leur épargner bien des tâches
la girafe était bien utile pour écurer
les gouttières le phoque n'avait pas son
pareil pour nettoyer le sol de la salle
de bain et grâce au kangourou et à sa
poche Colette n'avait plus apporté son
lourd Kaba quand elle faisait ses
courses tous les matins les œufs de
l'autruche constituaient un copieux
petit déjeuner et le singe rapportait
des fruits de tous les arbres du
quartier surtout Colette et Ernest ne
manquait jamais de compagnie et les
animaux dans leur nouveau foyer
recevaient enfin l'affection qui n'avait
jamais eu au zoo